and when you were at when you're at
you're a young comedian and your SNL for
[ __ ] sake Jesus Christ we all know
what that's like behind well actually
yeah but you know it's interesting I'm
from this different era of I come I'm
part of his wave that came along we come
after there's the 60s and 70s you know
60s there smoking pot 70s there doing
cocaine uh I come along in the 80s and
I'm part of this group of writers that
doesn't do it like we're watching our
cholesterol you know we're like with
that yeah we're in the room with people
who went into their offices maybe and
closed the door and did coke but we were
completely oblivious to it and you know
my writing partner at the time Greg
Daniels was was was like you know you
can't eat rye bread it's slightly like
Greg Greg Greg Daniels who created the
office and Parks and Recreation with
Mike Schur among others I I cannot
picture Greg Daniels taking an aspirin
no no yeah he wouldn't he wouldn't and
that was my writing partner and
I'm I mean I'm straight as an arrow he's
straight as an arrow
we're the most it's a ridiculous now is
a true story I went and had to get a
there's a couple years into my late
night show I had to get a physical and
insurance physical you know for my late
night show that cuz you know it's
required so I go and I'm getting his
physical from a doctor I don't know the
insurance company chose the doctor and
he's talking to me and then he said okay
alcohol and I go like yeah I mean I have
some wine but now you know did and he
said okay and what drugs do you do and I
said I don't do any drugs and he said
you know I'm a doctor this is
confidential and you need to be honest
with me and I said I don't do drugs and
he said you don't do cocaine and I said
no I don't do cocaine and he said I've
seen your show
[Laughter]